it is the first of May so it's time for
another monthly update video about all
the things that went on in April that
you might know about or might not know
about and all the things that we've got
coming up in May so you can put them on
your calendar and participate in them
we've got a lot of great stuff coming up
now I always like to begin with three
big things and this time around two of
those big things have to do with the
same sort or the same genre of matter so
big thing number one you may have seen
me release the video for this yesterday
I am offering an eight-week intensive
online
Aristotle course specifically on
Aristotle and the moral virtues looking
at them and Nick and McCann ethics books
two through six supplemented by a few
others this is an excellent opportunity
if you've ever wanted to study with me
we're going to do 90 minute class
sessions every week we're going to have
discussion forums all sorts of other
cool stuff I'll talk about that a little
bit more in the May section but I just
want to put that on your radar big thing
number two I haven't released this yet
but we're also doing starting at the
same day but a different time meeting as
well for 90 minute sessions an online
intensive class with me about Renee
Descartes meditations and the objections
and replies major major work of modern
Western philosophy if you've ever wanted
to study Descartes and you want an
expert guide well you might consider
registering for that class big thing
number three I'm going to be doing a lot
more writing this month I have some
projects having to do with book stuff
I'm also getting ready for two
conferences but I'll be doing a lot of
writing
in medium which is a website that I
publish my shorter pieces for you know
popular philosophy and sometimes I get
pretty technical with it but for the
most part it's for ordinary readers and
I'm going to be doing a lot more of that
now that the semester is at an end so
now let's talk about April
April has long since been kind of a
tough month in part because as an
academic I'm doing a lot of grading and
guiding students through their last few
weeks of class so that they can avoid
failing and get all their work in but in
the Sadler Shaka household it's also a
time where we had some significant
losses in our four-legged family three
years ago it was Amica our old girl dog
who was 14 years old who finally passed
away and then last year it was the sole
survivor The Sassy cat 19 years old who
finally died actually almost in my arms
she started dying in my arms and then I
we put her down and put her on her bed
and you know petted her and comforted
her as she passed away so that's you
know kind of a Melancholy time to
remember but you know it's also a good
time to see all the these great memories
that we have of the animals that we've
loved and you know to maybe to spend
some time as well taking care of other
animals now I mentioned classes are
coming to a close so that's a lot of you
know work on the academic front I you
know I'm buried in grading right now for
my Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
classes Marquette is going to end in May
so a lot going on there I also did a lot
of events in April I did my AMA that's
ask me anything we held our
understanding anger both in the online
class and then we recorded the class
session and did a video premiere so
people who aren't enrolled in the class
could also participate we got kind of a
double whammy with that I you know did a
wisdom for Life episode with my friend
and colleague Dan specifically about AIS
and large language models um we did a
video a self-directed study this time on
the cynic school had a lot of great
participation
in that and also I presented at the
Wisconsin philosophical Association on
the topic what is public philosophy
making what we call a pluralist proposal
about that and I'll talk more about that
in the May section
I went on four different uh podcasts or
shows to talk as a guest uh interview it
you know being interviewed about
particular things we had acid Horizon at
the beginning of April talking about
anger stoicism ancient philosophy the
anagage podcast where they're asking me
about like you know teaching in prisons
how I got started all of those sorts of
things radio Uninvited and then finally
finishing up the month with embodied
dialogue and I'll put links to all of
those just click the show more and you
can see exactly uh where we we did all
these these sorts of things what else
did we do well a lot of videos I
actually got another one of those ideas
that matter uh interview videos with
Jonathan B about Renee Gerard that's
that's a good one I did a Sadler's
stories about a drive that I had to take
I mentioned the understanding anger and
I shot core concept videos for my
classes but also for all of you on
Marcus Aurelius John Cassian and Seneca
the Marcus Aurelius his meditations John
Cassian uh the stuff from anger in in
book eight of his institutes and then
Seneca was on the shortness of life that
was for my philosophy mindfulness and
Life Class I also did uh quite a bit of
podcast work
releasing podcast episodes on Blaze
Pascal's ponce's on Aristotle's rhetoric
book two discussions of anger and
calmness and on lockedancius is on the
anger of God by the way I have early
released nearly all of those
lockedancius episodes to my patreon
supporters so if you'd like to get in on
you know early releases which I do
pretty routinely with my podcast stuff
they get to hear it before the general
public does sometimes you know days
sometimes weeks in advance so that's
something that's a nice perk for them
the last thing I'll mention so I talked
about medium right this month I actually
got quite a bit of writing done on
medium and there was something else that
was pretty cool that happened I'm now
the verified author of my 2011 book
reason fulfilled by Revelation the 1930s
Christian philosophy debates in France
so it takes a little while before they
do verify you I wrote two pieces on
Epictetus commentary on N Caribbean
chapter 12 and chapter 13. I also added
another seneca's lessons on Anger
Management number three in there expect
the unexpected I wrote a piece about
Marcus aurelius's reminders to himself
seven reminders to help keep your cool
not get ticked off at everybody I I also
did a few things that were sort of
resource oriented one about Epicurean
reading recommendations if you actually
want to study epicureanism you might
follow that and check it out and see
whether that helps you out and I also
did something about the self-directed
study I thought it was time to put all
the self-directed study resources in one
place so people could easily access them
and use them to help themselves out as
they engage in in studying philosophy
I also did a photo oriented one about
Sassy the cat time that we spent
outdoors in the Parks here in Milwaukee
wandering around you know in her harness
on her leash and even in her
grandmother's yard and then I also did
one on chant GPT and what chat GPT could
tell us about Borge's storytellan ukbar
orbius tertius which by the way
has some implications for large language
models and all that sort of stuff and it
turns out she had GPT not very good at
figuring those things out because
obviously it doesn't figure anything out
so that is what what went on during the
month of April now let's talk about May
we have a lot of really cool events
coming up some in person some online
during the month of May let me remind
you that all of the times that I'm
giving here are central time so you do
want to check out your time zone and you
can find links to all of these things
Below in the video description also on
the reason I O event calendar and uh
generally for most of these also on my
Facebook page under events so we kick
off the month in just a few days with a
local event here at the Frank Weinberg
library in Mequon Wisconsin and the
greater Milwaukee area philosophers in
the midst of History we're going to be
having our medieval session for May and
I'm going to be discussing Saint
Bonaventure the great Franciscan who
played such a major role in shaping The
Franciscan order so we'll be talking
about that that's always a great time
time great questions from the audience
on the sixth which is Saturday at noon
we'll have our regularly scheduled AMA
that's asked me anything session for
about 90 minutes I will do my best to
answer questions that people ask me
sometimes I have to say pass but most of
the time I have something to say
following that on the 6th at at 2 pm for
patreon supporters I will be having a
more exclusive philosophy chat that is a
video conferencing where we get to
discuss whatever is on people's minds
for about an hour so if you want to get
in on that you probably want to become a
patreon supporter on the seventh that's
that following Sunday at 11 A.M I will
be having another story time with Sadler
I'll be reading one of my favorite short
stories Graham greens the hint of an
explanation about a little boy and and
uh being tempted by a local guy in town
not to do anything sexual but something
sacrilegious so that might be of
interest to some of you uh on the 10th
that's a Wednesday at 5 p.m we'll have
our public Hegel q a and discussion
session video conferencing online you
can join in and ask questions about
Hegel German idealism philosophy more
broadly and I will do my best to answer
them uh following that on the 13th at
noon starting at noon because there's
two parts this we'll have the next
worlds of speculative fiction series
session and it's on Kim Stanley
Anderson's
um Mars Trilogy we're finishing up by
looking at the massive blue Mars the
longest book in the series and uh
following that I'll I'll be you know
shooting a video doing a Premiere
answering questions while the video
premieres then we'll have a video
conferencing session so that anybody
who's interested can chat about that
work Kim Stanley Anderson or speculative
fiction more more generally on the 20th
um at noon we'll be having our
understanding anger class so if you want
to get in on that class session where
we're going to be discussing anger in
Homer's Iliad lots and lots of anger
going on there the whole thing actually
begins with anger doesn't it you know
tell me oh Muse of the wrath of Achilles
so if you want to get in on that that's
a free online class that you have to
register for and once you do you get the
zoom link and you can join us for the
discussion then on the now this is the
big deal on the 25th at 10 A.M and then
at 1am those two online classes with me
one on Aristotle on the moral virtues
the other on Descartes meditations those
are beginning and you can sign up for
them ahead of time you know you can sign
up for them the day of if you want to
although I wouldn't wait around because
there are resources within the class
sites that you might want to make use of
there is a cost for them but I've kept
them as inexpensive as possible so as to
allow a lot of people to participate and
you're going to be able to study with
somebody who has been reading and
working on these texts for more than two
decades so those are going to be pretty
major on the 26th we have another local
event here right in the downtown at the
Women's Club of Wisconsin we'll be doing
our philosophy eats if you're interested
in that you need to contact the Women's
Club because they're the ones who handle
all of the scheduling for that I just
come and give the talk and then we have
a nice dinner and conversation this time
around we're going to be talking about
Nietzsche and nihilism so really
interesting stuff going on and then we
will be finishing up the month on the
27th at noon with another self-directed
study video this time it's going to be
about David Hume and how you can most
productively study his philosophy so
that's the all the events that are going
on in May what else is happening as I
mentioned you know we've got these cool
online classes I will also be bringing
out some other things that are not uh
synchronous online classes meeting for
90-minute class sessions but rather work
at your own pace classes as well on the
study with Sadler Academy and in some
other places as well so keep an eye out
for that video stuff I did shoot a half
hour Hegel video last month released it
to my patreon supporters of the project
and I'll be releasing it to the public
fairly shortly I also need to do the
book review videos that I keep meaning
to get to in this month of May now that
I'm not going to be teaching classes
except for you know finishing up the
Marquette class and of course doing my
online classes I should be able to get
some book reviews done that I've been
waiting for I also plan to do some more
ideas that matter interview videos
probably at least two of those I also
want to do some more Sadler stories
videos I had been planning to do a meme
Roundup for a while I might also do one
of those fake quotes videos we'll see if
I have the time for that and then I do
want to follow up with the majoring in
philosophy is that a good idea at this
point in time I want to update that
video I'm going to be doing some core
concept stuff uh on seneca's on anger on
aquinas's arguments about the existence
of God in the summer theologia and then
I plan this month to get to something
I've been wanting to do for quite a
while more speculative fiction studies
videos on Philip K dick and a long time
ago I did a a poll you know asking
people who they wanted me to do and or
what novel rather and man in the High
Castle like blew all the others out of
the water so I'm going to be doing some
speculative fiction studies on that
novel man in the High Castle I've got
some podcast stuff that I'll be doing as
well
continuing the series on lactancius I've
also got you know stuff that I I need to
do on the cynic Epistles written by
pseudocrates and I'll probably also do
those Marcus Aurelius videos that I did
recently I'm going to start converting
those over into Sadler's lectures
podcast episodes and I'll be doing a lot
of writing in medium perhaps in some
other venues as well so a lot going on
in May I hope that you have a great
month and that you can join me for some
of these online events and that some of
you will consider enrolling in these uh
eight week summer classes that I've got
coming up on Aristotle on the moral
virtues and on Renee Descartes
meditations objections and replies so
that's it for this update video
hopefully I'll see you somewhere in the
interwebs and have a great month